توتر اقليمي بين عدد من دول البحر المتوسط
سببه حقول غازي واكتشافاته طاقه امر دفع
الرئيس المصري عبد الفتاح السيسي مؤخرا
لاصدار قرار لترسيم الحدود البحريه
الغربيه للبلاد
فبحسب صحيفه الشرق الاوسط تضمن نص القرار
قوائم الاحداثيات الخاصه بالحدود
ويستهدف المحافظه على ثروات مصر وحقوقها
في غاز البحر المتوسط واكتشافات الجديده
لحقول الغاز
قرار يبدو فيه ان مصر ارادت ايصال رسائل
متعدده احداها قانونيه لتاكيد انه على
جميع الاطراف المعنيه احترام قواعد
القانون الدولي في ظل توتر قائم بشان
عمليات التنقيب عن الغاز واخرى تحمل
خلفيات سياسيه وامنيه الهدف منها اظهار ان
مصر لن تنتظر احدا للدفاع عن مصالحها
وحمايه حقوقها
الى جانب ان الانقسام السياسيه في ليبيا
الذي بات بحسب مشرعين المصريين مساله
مهدده للامن القومي المصري
خصوصا مع اقدام حكومه عبد الحميدبا منتهيه
الولايه على توقيع اتفاقيات لترسيم الحدود
البحريه مع انقره اضافه لاتفاقيهبه سبق
لاردوغان والسراج توقيع اتفاقيه امنيه مع
رفض تركيا الاعتراف باتفاقيه الامم
المتحده لقانون البحار لعام
وكان كل هذا كافيا لاقدام مصر على هذه
الخطوه من اجل حمايه حدودها ومواردها